[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen schön dass ihr wieder
dabei seid ich bin Toni Hayer und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir hallo wir haben euch
in diesem Sommer den Fall von Ursula
Herrmann erzählt die 1981 in Bayern
entführt wurde und der Titel der Episode
Tod in der Kiste der sagt ja schon dass
die Geschichte nicht gut ausging falls
ihr diese Folge noch nicht gehört habt
ihr findet sie unter eben genannten
Titel in eurem Podcast Channel und als
ich von unserem heutigen Fall erfahren
habe musste ich sofort an den Fall
Ursula Herrmann denken das ist eine
Sache die gehört nie auf letztendlich
kommt hier vor wenn ich das sehe als
wäre das letzte Woche voll letzte Woche
das ist eine Sache die wird immer
präsent sein das war die Stimme von
Johannes Erlemann auch er wurde entführt
ebenfalls im Jahr 1981 aber er hat
glücklicherweise überlebt
bei RTLplus gibt es über diesen Fall
jetzt sogar einen Spielfilm und auch
einen Podcast mit Silvana Katze und
Lorena Rahe und im nächsten Jahr wird
auch ein Buch über den Fall erscheinen
die Links die ist dazu gibt die packen
wir euch natürlich in die Show Notes und
weil uns der Fall Ursula Herrmann so
berührt hat wollen wir euch hier bei
Tatort Deutschland auch die Geschichte
von Johannes Erlemann erzählen dass er
seine Entführung überlebte ist der große
Unterschied zum Schicksal der kleinen
Ursula aber wir hören werdet ist es
trotzdem kein Happy End aber von vorne 6
märz 1981 18 Uhr Johannes Erlemann 11
Jahre alt ist in seiner Heimatstadt Köln
auf dem Heimweg in einem Interview mit
dem Stern erinnert er sich später so
es war ein grauer nass kalter Freitag
auf dem Weg nach Hause habe ich die drei
Männer schon aus der Ferne gesehen die
standen da halt so rum die Kapuzen tief
ins Gesicht gezogen ich freute mich auf
das Wochenende und fuhr ihnen
unbekümmert entgegen dann ging alles
sehr schnell einer der Männer riss mich
vom Rad ein anderer drückte mir einen
Lappen mit Chloroform ins Gesicht
Zitat Ende die Männer stecken ihn in
einen Lieferwagen und zwingen ihn in
einen Umzugskarton johannes hat vom
ersten Moment an Todesangst in dem
Karton ist das eng und die Fahrt kommt
ihm ewig lang vor als sie endet wird
Johannes in einen Verschlag unter der
Erde gesperrt er ist zwei Meter lang 150
breit und einen Meter 60 hoch von all
diesen fürchterlichen Umständen ahnt
Johannes Mutter nichts aber sie
alarmiert am späten Abend die Polizei
Beamte suchen noch in der gleichen Nacht
mit Spürhunden nach dem Kind sie finden
aber nur das Fahrrad des Jungen
und Polizei so schnell und so
entschieden reagiert das hat auch mit
einer Besonderheit dieses Falles zu tun
die justizkante die Familie nämlich
schon gut genauer gesagt Johannes Vater
Jochem Erlemann Joachim Georg kurz
Jochem Erlemann wuchs in Österreich und
dem Ruhrgebiet auf in Essen und Köln
ging er zur Schule wo er später auch
studierte und 1965 seinen Abschluss als
die Blumenkauf meiner Erfahrung im Laufe
seines Berufslebens arbeitete er als
Manager bei Karstadt dann für eine
Anlagegesellschaft und schließlich
selbstständig Erlemann suchte für seine
Kunden nach steuerschlupflöchern bei
Aktien und baugeschäften aber 1980 wurde
Erlemann verhaftet weil er Anteile für
ein betrügerisches Projekt mit
Gasflaschen im Libanon verkauft hatte
der Schaden soll 100 Millionen betragen
haben alle Mann wird zu 8 Jahren Haft
verurteilt die ab 1982 im offenen
Vollzug verbringen darf danke Mirko kurz
gesagt sitzt Johannes Vater also im
Knast als der Junge entführt wird Jochem
Erlemann hatte zwei Söhne aus erster Ehe
war zweimal geschieden und lebte nun
zumindest bis zur Haft in Köln und zwar
mit Johannes Mutter und dessen Bruder
Andreas die Familie residiert in einem
großen Haus im Stadtteil Hahnwald einem
der exklusivsten und teuersten
willenviertel Deutschlands drei Tage
nach Johannes verschwinden wollen
Polizeibeamte von seinem Inhaftierten
Vater wissen was er von der Sache hält
aber einen Verdacht habe und tatsächlich
beschuldigt der Betrüger Jochen Erlemann
zwei Bekannte die Entführung so mutmaßt
er munter vor sich hin gehe
höchstwahrscheinlich auf das Konto
seiner früheren Geschäftspartner Helmut
klein und Navi die beiden sein ohnehin
seit langem in kriminelle Geschäfte
verwickelt um es gleich vorwegzunehmen
die Geschichte stimmt nicht was auch
immer man den genannten Männern
vorwerfen kann mit dem Kidnapping haben
nichts zu tun während Eltern und
Ermittler noch im Nebel tappen muss
Johannes sich mit seinen neuen
Lebensumständen arrangieren vor acht
Jahren hat er sich in der Talkshow
Maischberger an die Zeit im Verschlag
erinnert da war wie das sagt ähnliche
Situation und ich wenn ich war 16 Tage
vergraben unter der Erde ich wusste
nicht wann Tag und über Nacht ist das
war völlige Dunkelheit und ich war
angekettet und war in einer Situation in
der diese Zeit halt nicht ändert und die
halt auch von sehr unterschiedlichen
gefühlssituationen geprägt das heißt das
passierte als das losgehen ich meine
will ich jetzt mal ohne dass der Kasse
zu meinen da hatte ich nur todesanze vom
Fahrrad gegriffen
und hatte auch diese ganzen Gefäß sie
haben mich dann auch dahin begleitet und
das war auch wirklich nicht einfach
die Entführer haben Johannes nicht nur
verschleppt und eingesperrt sie zwingen
ihn auch noch die Kommunikation mit
seinen Eltern zu übernehmen Johannes
muss Nachrichten auf Kassette sprechen
die dann an die Villa in Köln geschickt
werden eine lautete so
hallo hallo Mami mir geht es hier ganz
gut ich kriege hier essen Chips und so
du brauchst dir keine Sorgen zu machen
und keine Angst Samstag bin ich ja
wieder bei Euch hoffentlich und nur
wegen mir braucht er Andreas eine
Geburtstagsparty nicht abzubrechen
in einer ersten Nachricht fordern die
Entführer 8 Millionen marktlöse Geld
später lassen sie sich auf drei runter
handeln Johannes erträgt seine
Verschleppung und den Aufenthalt im
erdverschlag so gut erkannt irgendwann
weiß er nicht mehr wann Tag oder Nacht
ist und nach einigen Tagen platzt ihm
der Kragen das einer Situation heraus in
Plastik völlig angeschrien hat gesagt
ihr müsst was willst du machen das war
aber wirklich in diesem Karton auch
verreckt das war nicht zu ertragen ich
habe angefangen hat gesagt ihr müsst was
mitmachen das geht so nicht weiter
und dann gehen wir wieder dieser Deckel
runter und dann dachte ich oh Gott was
passiert gemacht jetzt ist irgendwas
großer Fehler das war ein Tag am Stille
und dann ging dann Tag lang aber diese
ganze Luke auf und dann kam jemand rein
ist erstmal mit mir gesprochen hat
und der sagte wir spielen jetzt Karten
es gehört zu den skurrilen Facetten des
Falls dieses Kartenspiel das Wort an
regelmäßig abgehalten wird zumal beide
Kind und Entführer es mit großem
ernstspielen am Ende der Entführung hat
Johannes 600 Mark dabei die er beim
Pokern gewonnen hat aber natürlich
wollen die Entführer die Situation
möglichst schnell beenden und mit einem
fetten Lösegeld entkommen wieder muss
Johannes auf Kassette sprechen
heute ist Freitag der
13.3.1981 ich wünsche Andreas alles Gute
und Liebe zum Geburtstag schade dass ich
nicht bei euch sein kann nun muss ich
dir sagen was du zu tun hast damit ich
wieder nach Hause komme du sollst das
Geld in zwei handliche Stofftaschen
packen und ich Montag nachmittag
bereithalten du wirst dann von jemandem
abgeholt der hat einen Brief für dich in
dem steht wo er mit dir hinfahren soll
und was du tun musst du musst ganz
alleine mitfahren du brauchst keine
Angst zu haben die Leute haben
versprochen dass dir gar nichts passiert
wenn du allein und ohne Polizei kommst
Johannes kann nur hoffen dass seine
Entführer seine Mutter und die Polizei
alles glatt über die Bühne bekommen also
die Lösegeldübergabe seine Freilassung
aber erstmal geht alles schief und auch
wenn das Pokerspiel den Eindruck erweckt
dass die Entführer ein Herz haben sie
handeln seelisch sehr grausam Jahre
später erinnert sich Johannes Erlemann
gegenüber der Zeit sie schafften es
meine Hoffnung zu brechen sie erzählten
mir die Geldübergabe sei gescheitert ich
sah meiner Mutter nichts wert die
letzten Tage vergingen in einer Art
Schwebezustand ich dachte keine ganzen
Sätze mehr nur noch Wörter
einer der Entführer kam zu mir er hatte
vergessen seine Maske aufzuziehen das
war sein scheiß Fehler aber mich hatte
dafür bestraft er schrie mich an er
drohte mich jetzt umzubringen ich hatte
nur einen Wunsch dass sie mich nicht da
unten an den Handschellen verrecken
lassen dass sie mich lieber in einen
Teich werfen
Werbung okay stellt euch mal vor es ist
Winter ihr seid in einer großen Stadt in
den USA in Baltimore es ist eine kalte
Silvester Nacht die ganze Stadt feiert
gerade ausgelassen doch plötzlich aus
dem Dunkeln fallen tödliche Schüsse die
alles verändern mit catch the killer
kommt am 5 Oktober endlich mal wieder
eine richtig gut gemacht da Thriller in
die Kinos der Film handelt von einer
FBI-Agentin die Jagd auf einen
flüchtigen Massenmörder macht und der
könnte jederzeit wieder zuschlagen der
Film erinnert an so Klassiker wie das
Schweigen der Lämmer und von der Presse
da wird er gerade als echter Geheimtipp
gefeiert also wenn ihr Lust habt auf
Verbrecher Jacken auf abgründige
Charaktere einfach auf gut gemachtes
Spannungskino catch the killer ab 5
Oktober überall im Kino
Werbung Ende
aber es kommt doch noch zu einer
Lösegeldübergabe beim zweiten Mal bringt
die Mutter das Geld zu einer Kiste im
Wald Erlemann erinnert sich bei
Maischberger das Kindern
Versuch ging es dann los und endete dann
an dieser Kiste die so abgedeckt war
dass man nicht sehen konnte dass sie gar
keinen Boden hatte Deckel da sollte sie
das Geld also rein tun das hat er
gemacht von der Polizei geschaltet was
sie eigentlich nicht wollte aber es war
nun doch so und ich sollte danach am
nächsten Morgen nach Hause kommen aber
das Problem war das Geld war abgegeben
ich kann nicht nach Hause und es kam
auch niemand zu der Kiste das ist und
Fall wo man sagt okay die Polizei hatte
die Kisten nicht aus den Augen gelassen
was ist jetzt die haben Angst bekommen
jetzt ist doch was passiert Kind ist tot
keiner geholt das Geld die sind über
alle Berge und dann hat die Polizei erst
den ganzen Tag noch gewartet er hat sie
die ganze Nacht doch darauf gewartet und
da gestern darauf folgenden Tag als ich
dann wenn jemand erbarmt und ist dann zu
der Kiste hingegangen
Geld da ist gar kein Geld mehr drin weil
die Kiste stand auf dem Kanal Deckel und
die haben das mit dem Kanaldeckel diese
geldtaschen dann darunter gelassen den
Kanaldeckel und sind dann mit dem
Schlauchboot kilometerweit vier oder
fünf Kilometer weit unter Köln
entlangerodet einer Freilassung des
Kindes steht jetzt nichts mehr im Wege
aber selbst diese letzten Schritte
werden für den 11-jährigen Johannes zur
Hölle er erinnert sich so sie holten
mich nachts aus dem Verschlag sie taten
mich auf einen Feldweg sie legten mich
dort auf den Acker sie begannen zu
diskutieren was machen wir mit dem lass
den uns überfahren sie stiegen ins Auto
sie hielten mit laufendem Motor 20 Meter
von mir entfernt
sie würden mich überfahren
ich könnte mich nicht bewegen mein
Kreislauf war am Eimer
dann fuhren sie davon ich schaute in die
Sterne das war der glücklichste Moment
meines Lebens
Johannes besorgt sich ein Taxi und fährt
nach Hause das muss so unvorstellbar
gewesen sein ich krieg da richtig
Kribbeln bei der Vorstellung du bist 11
eigentlich steht dein ganzes Leben noch
vor dir aber bis vor kurzem hättest Du
jederzeit sterben können und dann kannst
du mit dem Taxi nach Hause es ging
überall ich dachte dass wir gar nicht
mehr im Haus das ganze Haus war
stockfinster und ich wollte diese Sache
man hat mit 11 so ein bisschen das
Gefühl ob man nicht vielleicht selber
irgendwie eine Schuld an den ganzen
Vorfällen trägt die Sache selbst auch zu
Ende bringen und so kam ich halt nur ein
Taxi nach Hause lief diesen Weg da
entlang der Taxifahrer den habe ich dann
weiter geschickt der ist direkt 200
Mittag später verhaftet worden und bin
dann auf dieses Haus zugelaufen und da
war niemand und dann ging plötzlich über
Lichter an und plötzlich waren 40 50
Leute um mich herum die alle nur
geschrien haben gesagt haben niemand
fast den jungen Mann und meine Mutter
kam von oben mal runtergelaufen sie
wurde auch eine festgehalten Treppenhaus
und dann kam direkt ein Menschen die
mich erst später nackt ausgezogen haben
Datensicherung
hier ist das deutsche Fernsehen mit der
Tagesschau so flimmert Johannes Erlemann
1981 über die Fernsehschirme der
Republik ein hübscher blonder
11-jähriger im weißen Bademantel der
einem Reporter ganz cool erklärt dass
sie sich freut wieder frei zu sein wie
wir gleich noch hören werden fing
Johannes Leidensweg hier erst richtig an
aber erstmal schauten alle auf die
Fahndung nach den Tätern zu ihnen gibt
es zum einen die Beobachtungen die
Johannes in den zwei Wochen seines
Martyriums gemacht hat zum anderen
hinterlassen sie seit dem Ende der
Entführung eine Spur verpassten Geldes
wenige Wochen später werden sie in einem
Hamburger Bordell festgenommen nächster
Eintrag in dieser Chronik
22.09.1981
Prozess wegen erpresserischen
menschenraumes vor dem Kölner
Landgericht Urteil der Haupt Angeklagte
erhält 10 Jahre Haft seine Helfer müssen
acht und drei Jahre Haft absetzen ja
aber was wird aus Johannes ergibt so
erinnert er sich den Jungen an dem alles
abperlt absolviert Schule und Internat
geht danach aus NRW nach München gründet
eine Familie wird Medienmanager und fast
40 Jahre nach den Geschehnissen ermutigt
ihn seine Frau das erfahrene auch
öffentlich zu verarbeiten und zwar mit
einem Buch und einem Film denn wie alle
Mann schon 2015 bei Maischberger sagt
er will nicht einfach nur ein Opfer sein
am 6 märz 1981 habe ich die Kindheit in
dieser Kiste begraben und die kam auch
nicht mehr zurück ich habe das nicht
freiwillig getan aber es war auch nicht
mehr zurück sondern weil das Leben
danach das bitte nicht so mit dem zu tun
was vorher war das dann äußere Spuren
ich war angekettet an Handschellen ich
habe jetzt hier noch immer meine Narben
aneinander ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
es ist das kleinste ich meine ich will
es nicht vergleichen die Entführung die
war wirklich von ganz eigener brisant
aber die Zeit danach die war in
derartige höhlenritt über Jahre dass ich
für mich irgendwo erstmal aus dem Gefühl
heraus erkennen musste kein Opfer zu
sein das war für mich auch immer so ein
bisschen diese Situation auch jetzt hier
heute man ist dann entführungsaufsicht
mich nicht als Opfer ich habe immer sehr
darüber bemüht mein Leben zu leben und
das auch davon mit mir fernzuhalten weil
ich will nicht irgendwie ein Opfer das
ist ein bemitleidenswerter Mensch der
seine Schublade ist nicht sein wollte
ich habe mir das auch nicht ausgesucht
und deswegen ist der Kampf daraus zu
kommen viel viel schwerer
Johannes Erlemann kämpft sein Leben lang
also um Normalität seine Entführer haben
das auf ihre Weise längst getan der
Haupttäter der seine Strafe schon vor
Jahren abgesessen hat ist mittlerweile
erfolgreiche Unternehmer die Namen der
Täter dürfen aus Gründen der
Resozialisierung auch gar nicht mehr
öffentlich genannt werden einer von
ihnen äußerte später sogar öffentlich
sein Bedauern er schrieb es gibt für
dieses Verbrechen keine Entschuldigung
es tut mir leid dass Johannes Erlemann
bis heute unter den furchtbaren
Ereignissen zu leiden hat ich habe meine
Strafe aber verbüßt und ich habe meinen
Anteil des lösegels längst zurückgegeben
durch weitere öffentliche Forderungen
fühle ich mich zum zweiten Mal
verurteilt und was sagt Johannes
Erlemann dazu ganz einfach dieser Mensch
hat sich mit dieser Äußerung an eine
Zeitung gewandt bei mir hat er sich
nicht gemeldet und deshalb spielt es
auch keine Rolle
und damit kommen wir wieder zum Anfang
im Gegensatz zur Entführung von Ursula
Herrmann hat Johannes Erlemann überlebt
glücklicherweise und für den Täter ist
die Sache mit der strafverbütung
offensichtlich abgeschlossen für das
Opfer aber und das gilt wohl für alle
Opfer von Gewalt sind die Nachwirkungen
und folgen dieser schrecklichen
Ereignisse oft ein Leben lang spürbar
sie sind damit in gewisser Weise zu
lebenslänglich verurteilt zu
lebenslänglicher Erinnerung an ihre
Todesangst
was hast du gut gesagt Mirko und umso
besser wenn Leute wie Johannes Erlemann
ihre Geschichte nicht den Tätern oder
Dritten überlassen sondern sie selbst in
die Hand nehmen wie versprochen packen
wir euch natürlich die Infos zu dem
Podcast bei RTL dem Film und auch das
Buch in die Show Notes und wir danken
euch natürlich dass wir heute wieder
zugehört habt
es gibt diese Episode Stefan Netze Band
Aufnahme und schnitt tonija
Postproduktion weight watch Studios
München bis zum nächsten mal euer Mirko
und eure Toni